hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and I'm double boiler now why did you
big devil doesn't take any sense but
mrs. jammers never seen and that's never
seen and today we're watching the
original Texas Chainsaw Massacre I
absolutely try watching this when I was
in high school some would argue the best
way on shitty VHS it was it was so
shitty though and like it was all orange
and black I could barely make it out
that's just like and I think I got up to
the first kill away yeah but everyone
says it's a classic you know it's like
this incredible film so I figured okay I
should give this a chance I didn't
realize there were eight of them I
always thought like maybe there's the
first and then I've only seen that
Jessica Biel remake of it did you see
that before this one oh yeah okay and I
really liked that movie
I haven't seen any of them so this is
totally brand-new the Jessica Biel
remake one was something I watched in
high school and it was one of the first
like horror slasher films I had ever
seen and I loved it I'm excited to watch
this and see if it like aged well if it
lives up to like the gross Ness of what
leather faces or if it's beautifully
dated either it's timeless or
beautifully dated I'm always hoping for
one of those - yeah that's a good way to
put that yeah Lisa will a let's find out
what towba first yeah I'm happy it was a
family picture this was exactly what I
thought would be and the exact opposite
of what I thought it would be somehow
what do you mean by that
okay it's so I knew there's gonna be a
guy going around killing people with a
chainsaw that kind of goes without
saying but then you get to like the last
third where like the killer is wearing
makeup and stuff and there's more people
it's this weird dinner scene and I have
no idea what or why they were doing any
of that and just the whole style and
everything is so strange I mean I've
been through some tense dinners in my
life I've never been the intense dinner
hey we have fun
I had like a mild stomach ache
throughout this entire thing there's a
real
uneasiness to the whole thing anyway
we've just seen a lot more films and
stuff like that but yeah there's
something not just sort of the gritty
style and the whole seventy style of it
but just this general unnerving this to
the way that guy comes out and the way
he kills people in a film today I feel
like him just throwing these people
around and throwing like the girl in the
ice box and stuff like that what kind of
be seen as funny but he's just so
massive and so creepy that you just
can't believe how he's throwing these
people around like they're nothing yes I
think my favorite part of the entire
film talking about him coming out is
your first reveal of Leatherface is
there's no music cue he opens up and
it's silent and then he grabs the guy
and then shuts the door and it's like no
you would probably get like a very
dramatic music here or at least
something there and it was so silent and
I was just like that's the most
terrifying door closed I was kind of
like what funny note about this movie
and my friend Jason law has told me this
he's a horror fanatic he knows all about
this uh this was originally supposed to
be a PG movie now let me explain that
because it does make sense riggers the
Lost Ark is PG and there's heads blowing
up and people get stabbed through the
you know eyes and heads and on stuff
like that I don't know why I said eyes
that doesn't happen anyway so PG
actually meant parental guidance back
then like look this is not for everyone
you know you may want this this is a
tough movie that are it's like absolute
adults like you know don't bring the
kids at all now peaches like frozen and
inside out I like theirs if someone says
the word sex it's like a peachy you you
know something like that we're back then
it really meant something it was really
warranted so this guy if you think about
it was not really showing much of gore
at all you get a little bit like the
bodies and in the opening but you know
what when he puts the woman on the hook
and everything you don't see a thing
yeah it's just all suggesting the acting
is so good so apparently people were
really discussed and they saw it it's
like well of course it's an arm was so
fake and I wake up I really felt for the
character
I think the acting was really well done
I wasn't expecting that I think I think
I was expecting it oh you know it's like
a yeah it's like a horror slasher like
it's just gonna be like silly the acting
was very convincing what I love is
especially in the 90s when you saw like
a person in a wheelchair it's like oh
that's the person in the wheelchair if
the wheelchair trope or whatever like we
just got to get in you know and there's
the black kid and there's the girl in
there and like this person is in a
wheelchair but he's not the wheelchair
guy like he is really weird and out
there and funny and I just love the shit
out of it but he was also pain too so
funny Holly which is so good cuz he's
like well-rounded he's not like this
sympathetic character in a wheelchair it
was like he's just a person I think my
favorite character was the hitchhiker
brother that they pick up he was
terrified know scary he was like maybe
creepier than Leatherface yeah who is
also very creepy and yes James Franco
with a birthmark
I wrote down James Franco I also thought
Walter and again I mean it's just like
it's just so early the creepiness kind
of starts where it's just like II all he
has is a knife he just looks at a guy's
knife and it's like so tense you just
have no idea what he's gonna do and it's
not just a fake out he legitimately
comes through it just starts cutting
someone but it takes a really long time
and they're just like okay can we trust
you can we not you I think because you
really feel like you're in that car
there's not a sense of like we'll just
stop and kick him out or whatever like
it it doesn't look that easy absolutely
and what you said with time with
something that multiple times I was like
now that would have just been a jump to
like the next scene in the end the girl
after the dinner scene or before the
dinner scene she escapes she gets then
tied up by the guy at the gas station
and then she's in the car they're about
ready to go and he's like Oh left the
light on and you see him get up yeah
don't you're gonna light up why there is
so much time to take it throughout the
movie and I was like that would be so
different now and say I enjoy it it's
like immediately scary and funny at the
same time then just for no reason he's
just hit her with the broom stick it
what a dumb
than a broomstick so silly and strange
but also just so creepy because you do
feel like you're kind of there yeah and
it just lets you sit in that awful
disgustingness I would say the biggest
point for me with that is the dinner
scene just lingers so long actually
that's the one part I was almost getting
born there the grandma that was really
really uneasy like I was very like
creeped out by him I watched the second
one after I watched this one and they
got more of a budget and the grandpa got
better makeup and it was way less
effective okay no no here's what I was
wondering cuz I was watching this I'm
just like is that a mask or is that
supposed to be a skin I think is
creepier imagining that as a mask cuz
Leatherface wears a mask wait I always
thought Leatherface way over roar is
that music oh I didn't no idea that's
what Leatherface sounded like he always
danced at the end like I was giggling
throughout it's like really fun I love
that end sequence of her driving away
laughing and like him like doing like an
interpretive day I could tell he was
happier mad now like she got away with
you know he's like oh no he got away go
tell your friends anytime there's a
chase scene in this don't you be like
feel like he's right behind you like you
know Liam I really want you Ron run
closer get closer and that one scene at
the end it's just the truck is there and
she gets in when he's getting towards
the door like something about the way
they should it just really looks like
he's closed it he's gonna get you yeah
okay here's my question though get in
the truck they close they starts hitting
the door or whatever why didn't they
just drive off why why did they just
drive the hell out through the door
we'll just go out the other door the
best though is when he drives up and he
opens the door and he gets out he's like
what's going on that he sees Leatherface
of me and then the other car comes up
and they just run towards the other car
it just really feels chaotic I love when
she goes in the house which is army
great cuz you know there's nothing but
terror in there so I'm like well
whatever habit she goes in the house
she's dead she stays out there she's
dead just either way she's gonna be and
she actually lives but she goes in the
house
which was already great cuz he's chasing
after her and in horror movies they
always look out the window they're like
um she doesn't think she just dives out
the window yeah I feel like people going
in kinda know what it's gonna be it's
gonna be that exploitation style movie
that's super gritty and super you know
odd an uncomfortable kind of artsy that
yeah and you can see all these are films
that came from it like The Devil's
Rejects and stuff like that like just
this whole genre and style kind of came
from this movie thank you so much for
watching next week we are doing human
centipede together so watching human
centipede to notify there's somebody's
like ready to click connect to it yes
like we're not
[Music]
[Applause]
you